Her name is Astray. She's a teacher.
She's asking that we learned that Allah
is most merciful and most loving.
Um her question is does Allah still love
sinners habitual sinners or good
behaving kafir? If that is the case why
did Allah created jannam to burn the
kafir?
>> This is the question does Allah love the
sinners?
And if he loves the sinner, does he love
the kafir?
Kafir is a person who rejects Islam,
rejects the teaching of the Quran and
Allah. So why is he created hell? The
reply to your first question is Allah
does not love the sinners.
Allah loves the person who runs away
from sin.
Allah does not love the kafir. He loves
the person who accepts his will to
almighty god. He loves the Muslims.
Muslim is a person who submits his will
to almighty god. Now this life Allah
says in the Quran in surah mulk chapter
number 67 verse number two
it's Allah who has created death and
life to test which of you is good in
deeds. So this life is a test for the
hereafter.
I'm asking you a question.
Does a teacher like a student who passes
or a student who fails?
Will a teacher like a student who passes
or will a teacher like a student who
fails?
She's translating
>> the one who passes.
>> The teacher will not love the student
who fails. Why? Because the teacher is
there to give guidance and the person is
not paying attention. He's not listening
to the teacher. And if the teacher
fails, why is the teacher failing the
student? Same way Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala has given the choice for all the
human beings. He gives them chance in
this world. If they make a mistake, he
gives one more chance. He makes a
mistake again.
But once you die, the test is over. In
this world, Allah gives hundreds of
chances to human beings. You make a
mistake, Allah forgives you, give you
another chance, another chance. But
when you die, your test is over. If you
die as a mushri,
worshiing somebody else besides Allah or
you die as a kafir, rejecting the truth
of Islam, then you have no choice. Allah
says on the day of judgment, the kafir
will never object to the justice of
Allah. They will only chance. Allah
would say too late. What will the kafir
come alone in the world and do even
we'll have to come back here? So why do
we want to come back to the world? We
have already passed the test. So the
kafir, the Quran says will never object
to justice of Allah. They will agree
that they were wrong. They'll only say
give us one more time, one more chance,
Allah will say it's too late. So this
life is a test. If you pass, you get a
reward. If you fail, you get a
punishment. Hope that answers the
question.
Aonum.